trump administration has a long-standing
pattern of taking moves against
international organizations such as the
international criminal court
the world health organization or the u.n
human rights council
but it appears that one international
organization the world anti-doping
agency is capable of retaliating if the
united states takes measures against it
we've been approached by a number of
governments of the world that were
shocked with the threats from the u.s
government
these governments want us to consider an
amendment to the compliance standard
meaning that non-payment by a government
of its wider contribution
could lead directly to being declared
non-compliant with the world anti-doping
code
inevitably this could have serious
repercussions for athletes
including their participation in major
international sporting events
this comes after the june white house
drug control policy report
which indicates that the united states
has taken measures
against wada working to defund the
organization for years the united states
has provided the world anti-doping
agency with millions of taxpayers
dollars in annual dues
far more than any other nation in the
world we do so with an expectation that
vada will operate in a transparent
accountable and independent manner that
is above all else fair to athletes
they deserve a fair shake and devote a
commitment to guaranteeing competition
on level playing field although these
threats were not made
publicly we've already heard the u.s
olympic committee
as well as the u.s anti-doping agency
speak
up against any proposal
threatening u.s athletes over this is
one of the most terrible things i've
ever seen from wada
apparently non-payment is as serious as
systemic doping
where's the rule that says this and is
it applied to everyone
to threaten one country's athletes over
what has failed governance model
is pretty remarkable and disappointing
what is very threatened and rattled
but to legally threaten u.s athletes is
shameful
the u.s anti-doping agency says these
proposals are simply illegal the united
states cannot be
excluded as in the only country to be
locked
out simply because of this move to
defund
so it appears that the policy of the
white house in which they defund
international organizations that don't
suit the united states
will continue and it appears at this
moment retaliation will not be taking
place
if you want to be a member of a sports
club or a gym
you have to pay to take part you can't
just walk in and say listen i'm the
biggest
and the baddest on the planet you'll
give it to me for free it doesn't happen
like that
and they do have money and one thing i
will say about u.s anti-doping is that
they
are they are being cut out they are seen
as kind of um
you know insignificant in us sports
because remember
these guys do not test the nfl the nhl
the mlb or
nba or even any of the college sports
overlooked by the naia
and the ncaa so this is it's a very
serious matter and
you know what it's it's the opening
shots being fired ahead of the olympics
because of course the us anti-doping
they have been caught so
badly and have really let themselves
down by refusing to test
athletes during lockdown and right after
lockdown we saw these amazing world
records being broken and national
records and personal bests being broken
by athletes who travis tiger said were
not
training during lockdown so maybe the
rest has done them well
but this is just the opening volley in a
very very
nasty war